matt hancock very good morning to you i
mean you've called for a progressive
regulatory regime for cryptocurrencies i
mean the bank of england is constantly
warning about the risks posed by crypto
what do you know that they don't
well we can't be naive about crypto
it's here
it's being used around the world and
here in the uk
my argument is we need to embrace that
and we need to put in place a high
quality regulatory regime that yes takes
into account concerns uh like around
financial stability which are important
but doesn't just push this away because
it's happening and it's going to happen
and it'll be far far better if we can
attract crypto markets crypto exchanges
here in the same way that we have huge
amounts of foreign exchange trading in
in london and we've always been at the
forefront of financial innovation over
over decades
so the the key
is to make sure that we're on the front
foot and we embrace crypto and we think
hard about how best to yes have a
regulatory system and structure but one
that's liberal and allows people to
innovate and allows the new investments
to come here
what sort of ra regularly regulatory
regime would this look like though what
specifically could regulators be doing
to encourage more innovation in this
field
well i think the single most important
thing is that we don't
we don't squash innovation right you can
easily say let's have a regulatory
regime because there are concerns
understandable and real concerns like as
you mentioned about financial stability
also about consumer protection and for
instance the way that advertising is
done
but it's all too easy then to just try
to you know stamp out the whole thing
but that just means that crypto is going
to be
done elsewhere invested in elsewhere and
the through the ages the uk has done
well by getting investment here onshore
especially in fintech financial
innovation think of the euro bond market
in the 80s think of the scale of
of international foreign exchange
trading and it's about making sure that
we think about the innovation piece as
well as the risks and the concern i had
is that in the debate
understandably regulators are saying
well there's this risk and there's that
risk and they're
seriously problematic and of course
these things need to be looked at but
we've got to remember that being the
home to fintech is very strongly in
britain's national interest and it's
also a huge opportunity that we've got i
mean bitcoin which is obviously the best
known cryptocurrency is off by 46 since
early november i mean these are not
assets necessarily for widows and
orphans are they
well they're they're risk assets right
there are
there's different parts of of
cryptocurrencies the the stable coins
which are essentially part of the
payment system uh and then there's the
risk assets and yeah prices go up and
prices go down they go up and down in
equities as well you know you and i have
both been around long enough to have
seen the uh
uh the you know the the ups and downs of
equity markets over the years currencies
go uh up and down and
we we say caveat emptor we say that
you've got to you should invest what
your what you can
what you're prepared to lose
in high high risk assets so
that is about having a good regulatory
system so that people are aware of the
risks but let's let people take those
risks as well because it's only that way
that you're going to get the sort of
innovation that that can benefit us all
and that can make sure that london stays
ahead and you know with the freedoms
that we now have to to design our own
regulatory structures
we should be making sure that we can
attract new fintech of which uh uh you
know bitcoin and the other
cryptocurrencies are one example but
there's endless other examples of
innovations in this space and we should
be really embracing it that's that's
that's the case that i think needs to be
made to weigh against the understandable
concerns because otherwise you'd have an
imbalanced system
well look while we have you uh there's
obviously a photograph that's done the
rounds of what looks very much like a
party in the downing street garden where
you were attending what was going
through your mind when you were there
oh well
in that instance i mean i was in downing
street a lot during the pandemic
understandably
on the the day in question that you
talked about um i'd done the press
conference i went down to debrief the
prime minister
and then i left and all of that's for
the uh for the public record
and often there were meetings that were
held outdoors uh partly because it was
partly because it was safer um but what
we yeah what i was concentrating on was
obviously the huge amount of work that
we had to do during the pandemic and
that was at the forefront of my mind but
when other photographs emerged of you
apparently breaking lockdown rules you
resigned why is it you think that some
other members of the government have
seemingly got away with it
well i think you've got to look at the
big picture right it's been a tough
few years
but i think ultimately the government
has got the big calls right
if you look at the
for instance the vaccination program you
know we ended up with the
fastest vaccination program in europe
one of the fastest in the world not by
accident but because of actions taken
and decisions that we took
in order to make sure that we for
instance bought a head and bought a
basket of
uh
of vaccines
so that if in the end two of them came
off in in in big numbers oxford and uh
uh and pfizer and moderna to a slightly
smaller scale but still important
and we bought six
in the end we bought seven so that and
some of those didn't come off that's
actually about taking you know
knowing that not everything will come
off but going broad and investing across
a whole range of different options and
then in in our case two of them came off
and because of a very very innovative
uh health regulatory regime thanks to
the mhra you know we managed to get that
to
um to into people's arms as quickly as
possible so actually the there is a lot
of lessons from that in how we need to
regulate in the future as we can flex
our regulations post-brexit uh because
we managed in that case to say the
regulation of new vaccines
the phases should be done in
parallel instead of in series that
radically sped up the approvals process
the mhra used modern data techniques to
understand
the risks and to check that the vaccines
were safe and we need to make sure that
in a you know in a different sphere in
this case in health regulation that
that's dynamic as well and pro
innovation so actually you know i came
on to talk about cryptocurrency and
that's but it's actually a lesson that
we should learn from the pandemic right
across the board that you can improve
regulatory systems to get things quicker
to market or in the case of the vaccines
into the you know the arms of the
population okay whilst also protecting
against the risks right that's that's uh
all good and fun you've made that point
in the meantime of course your
colleagues are sending in letters of no
confidence to the 1922 committee
questioning the integrity of the prime
minister i mean do you still think he
has the moral authority to lead the
country and lead the party
yes because i think it comes back to
this big question about getting the big
calls right
and the vaccines is one example there's
other examples as well you know we're
one of the most open economies in the
world and for all the economic
challenges that we have and we have some
serious economic challenges and
obviously the the bank of england's
looking at the inflation data and we'll
hear from them later today
for all those challenges we do have the
fastest growing economy in the g7 and we
have one of the most open societies of
all major countries i mean it's easy to
forget that because we're sort of
getting back to normal and that here
um at least the
the the disease covered 19 is now
endemic not
pandemic that is a good thing but it
isn't true in many many other similar
countries across the world so look at
the big picture calls the vaccines the
consequence of the vaccines which is
that we're we're we're more open than
almost any comparator country uh and
you've got to you've got to look at the
big picture
sure the other big picture though is
that the prime minister's poll ratings
are in free fall i mean is this going to
do lasting damage to the conservative
party do you think
well i hope not and i think not i think
that what we have to concentrate on
is the future is on making sure that we
address the challenges ahead of us so
for instance making sure we get through
the backlog in the nhs but the on my
argument and one of the reasons that we
talked about you know me coming on today
is we've got to be pro innovation we've
got to be pro enterprise we've got to
make that argument more strongly than we
have because the only way out of the big
picture problems that we face
is through
enterprise and growth and making sure
that we get the investments here in the
uk we have a big opportunity to make
that happen so whether it's on
cryptocurrency or on uh
healthcare both of which we've talked
about right across the board we've got
to make sure we are the country that is
open to enterprise and we have a great
environment for enterprise and we have
the investment coming in here and that
is what worries me most frankly making
sure
that that as we come out of the pandemic
we can say to people who want to come
and take a risk come and take a risk
here in the uk well it worries a lot of
people tony danke from the cbi told us
this morning that uh the government's
condemning us to be high taxes and low
growth
well i actually i read his full article
and uh because i saw the headline and i
thought that's a bit of a surprise
coming from the cbi so i i read the full
article and actually it was remarkably
similar which is we've got to make sure
that we support enterprise we support
innovative fast-growing companies we
make it easy to make investments you
know most
most international companies
we need to make sure that the u their uk
arm is winning their argument at global
board level that the next investment
should be in the uk you know this is
where we need to be because it's how we
get ourselves out of the
you know the very significant economic
challenges that we like every country
around the world face